so alan
how do you how do you and this uh friend
of yours that you met tell us that story
how did this happen to come up with
these
13 indicators yeah i'd love to tell you
i came up with them with my
brilliant thinking but if i were to tell
you that to quote the late
not so great richard nixon that would be
wrong
in 1981 i was a distinguished visiting
scholar
at the california institute of tech
technology in pasadena
and there i met the russian vladimir
kylis borak the world's leading
authority
on earthquake prediction the head of the
institute
of pattern recognition and earthquake
prediction in moscow
and he suggested we collaborate and
being forsightful of course i said
we're not going to collaborate
earthquakes may be a big deal here in
washington d.c
but i have to go back excuse me in
southern california but i have to go
back to washington d.c
nobody cares about earthquakes i teach
at american university
and he said i don't want to do
earthquakes already solve that you know
right
get this he said in 1963
under president john f kennedy he was
part of the soviet scientific delegation
that negotiated the most important
treaty in the history of the world
by far the nuclear test ban treaty that
stopped us from poisoning the atmosphere
the oceans and the earth and he said
i fell in love with politics and i
always wanted to use the methods
of earthquake prediction to predict
elections but he said look
i live in the soviet union elections
forget it it's supreme leader or
off with your head but you know all
about
elections so we became the odd
couple of political research and i can
tell you
what happened after that if you want to
know i want to know about it tell me
okay so our key insight
was to reconceptualize presidential
elections
in earthquake geophysical terms
remember this is 1981 not as carter
versus reagan
not as republican versus democrat not as
liberal versus conservative but as
stability the party in power
keeps the white house and earthquake the
party in power is
turned out so the second big
insight was we were going to base
our model on the idea that american
presidential elections
are essentially votes up or down on the
strength and performance of the party
holding the white house
should we give them four more years and
so based on those two ideas
we looked at every american presidential
election
from 1860 the horse and buggy days of
politics
when abraham lincoln was elected to 1980
the modern europe when ronald reagan was
elected
and using the methods of pattern
recognition to see what patterns are
associated
with stability and earthquake we came up
with a 13 key
indicators the 13 keys to the white
house
and our simple decision rule
if six or more of the keys go against
the party holding the white house
they are predicted losers any
sixth it's a non-linear system